are you in heman mode right now getting
ready yes yes so what does that mean
what does that mean in human moment
really tell you like what the tricks are
to that hold of that whole game it's a
lot of work though is it I don't look
like a man and I need to look like
he-man so it's like it's great we're
doing a we're doing a lot of hard work
and it's every single day but it's
really fun and I like regimen so it's
good with me are you eating
or are they do they have you on one of
those crazy diets I don't know how much
I can say about like the tricks of the
trade
no nobody I don't know man the person
that straining is incredible and we're
on a diet and we're on a regimen and
it's strict strict yeah very et spoke
with Noah backstage at the MTV Movie and
TV Awards after winning best kiss and
breakthrough performance for his role in
the Netflix rom-com to all the boys I've
loved before best kiss goes to Noah said
today
thanks to a lotta slips right I just
wanted to say thank you didn't know her
for being an amazing partner can you
tell us anything about that one about
the next one
no there's a new love interest to like
watch off
[Music]